so this is a lot of fun this past
weekend i got to spend some time with
rob bell any rob bell fans here yes yes
he's a pastor and the author of
best-selling books like love wins and
what we talk about when we talk about
god and now most people go to him for
like pastoral advice or sp seeking like
spiritual counsel i went to him for surf
lessons
this is what we talked about when we
talked about surfing
hello everybody i'm here with one of my
best friends rob bell who's a
influential author a person who's
personally changed my life with his work
and he's now going to teach me to surf
as if you haven't done enough
now now teach me how to float amongst
the waves he's a pastor man of the lord
we're going to talk about god while we
serve cool yes do you think jesus ever
served or was definitely a real person
first thing you have to do you got to
wear a wetsuit this is your changing
room
i'm gonna get naked there's a lot of
balls in the air
and some of them i don't want on the
show
swinging like a grandfather clock it
gets easier the more you do it
this is what the x-men have to do every
time there's danger
okay so now um once you lay down on the
board
and then pop up onto your feet like this
position you're just worth
okay yes yes why are you laughing
hold on let this wave come through look
we'll just wait from there this wave
went actually gonna be fine okay jump up
on the board and get out
we're gonna die
hey rob
can i tell you a secret
i'm urinating
so we've been surfing for a little bit
now i've mostly been falling
is serving like a spiritual thing for
you very much so jesus talked about how
to live a particular kind of life now
compassion grace generosity standing up
to injustice being a person of integrity
but then but you take that and you put
it through the human filter of being
afraid of dying and you just get like
after life insurance right like a ticket
like you don't want to burn do you right
which like if that's the best message
you have right that's just a crap
message hey rob
but i'm i'm with you i want to surf in a
religious way i want to get dirty
i want to get tossed
i want to participate in it oh god
i think the ocean is all about love but
it wants a little respect
just kill a sermon and the second you're
like off the stage you want to be like i
killed that
tell me about your brain injury because
you were telling me about it on the
waves that's an awesome
segway
we'll put you in the now i was doing
backflips water skiing on a wakeboard
and i hit my head and i like had like a
closed head injury where i sort of had
to be
reacquainted with my life like this is
your wife this is your kid this is your
house my brain didn't have energy
to be thinking about the past which is
regret or the future which is anxiety
and worry it was only able to be fully
present right so
my wife made me a burrito and i could
taste
all of the different
spices i call it the eternal burrito it
was it was unbelievable
and what it did is exposed to me how
much of the time we're not here we're
talking to you but we're also wondering
if this is happening our brain is here
and here and here and here and here and
you're missing the salon and in every
religious tradition the great ones the
mystics the enlightened ones
the thing that the message they always
bring is
here
now
fully present taste your burrito we got
to do mushrooms i'm telling you we have
to do mushrooms you would just be going
around going the burrito is back
i'm in awe of enough things without any
external stimulants that's that's a good
response for a man that's never done
mushrooms before
can i tell you a secret
yeah
i'm urinating right now
you know that story where the man is
like hey i was walking on the beach with
jesus there's two sets of footprints but
then when times got hard there was only
one set and you left me and jesus liked
i didn't leave you that's when i was
carrying you
you know that story yes can we do that
he's a heavy man